so this is it
it's always ladies
ready let's go hey everybody really cool
news Leticia Wright who plays Sheree in
the Black Panther movie just said some
stuff in an interview recently that
confirmed one of my big spider-man
theories for future sequels during the
Avengers movies and then during
spider-man homecoming - whatever they
wind up calling the spider-man sequel so
I'm gonna play that clip it's from a
larger interview that they did so no
worries no spoilers for Black Panther
this is all Marvel phase 4 stuff that
she's talking about Sheree and
spider-man for latisha yes man Tom's my
friend and I was I was contemplating
helping him in the future with his suit
and stuff and just we were just going
back and forth but I think I would win
[Laughter]
[Applause]
well rumor has it that there is going to
be an epic battle so I don't know who
started that rumor but it may be just a
rumor the battle between Sharia
spider-man yeah thank you and let me off
okay all right
pretty cool right the vibranium future
of spider-man's costumes I had a bunch
of theories about how they might
integrate the Black Panther movie in the
technology into the future of Marvel
phase four all kinds of cool stuff like
you're like what if everybody gets
vibranium upgrades wouldn't that be so
awesome
now the actors that play Sheree says
that they're actually talking about that
on the set for the Avengers films so
when she's joking about being Tom's
friend and having scenes with him think
about spider-man's timeline during
infinity war like this like we see him
in the old version of the costume up on
Thanos his ship it looks like it slowly
pushes into orbit so he's starting to
freeze literally Ironman probably sends
the new armor after him to save him we
learn about how cool and shiny it is all
the secret functions that it has I made
a couple iron spider videos and they
just let that settle throughout the
course of Infinity Ward he's still
wearing it when Thanos smashes him like
a bug on this rock here it as far as we
know
these Avengers do not enter Wakanda
unless everybody is here for this big
outriders invasion towards the end of
the film so we can probably assume that
at least half of the Avengers are in
Wakanda by the end of the film and the
other half are with the Guardians in
outer space fighting Thanos himself I
don't know that they're all gonna be all
in the same place all at the same time
until Avengers 4 but here's the thing
when she said that she was talking to
Tom about these future vibranium
upgrades she was gonna help him out with
his suit just imagine the possibilities
they've already wrapped filming on
Avengers 4 meaning that the stuff that
they're talking about couldn't have been
for Avengers 4 so it sounds like what
happens is is in the wake of Avengers 4
and then finally defeating Thanos but
you have scenes like you had at the end
of the first Avengers film where Tony
Stark is looking at the blueprints for
the new Avengers facility literally in
the case of Shuri actually building a
better tomorrow and part of that is just
this future where they all talk to each
other a little bit more you see more
crossover in the phase for movies Marvel
has already figured out that two
superheroes in a movie is better than
one superhero so you have Iron Man and
spider-man homecoming obviously there's
gonna be another Avenger level character
in the second spider-man film but it's
also the same for all the other Marvel
phase 4 films so like Thor is probably
gonna pop up in someone else's film
before he gets another solo film like
Chris Hemsworth said he's totally down
to do another thorpe belt hanging up
Thor's hammer is that true well my
contracts coming to an end we've just
finished the last two Avengers and who
knows what what the future holds you
know we had felt like we kind of
reinvented that last one in a big way
and felt refreshed and re-energized so
we mined up conversations if there's a
you know another great script that comes
along but at the moment but he's just
waiting for the right script so it's
probably not gonna happen for a while
but in the way that you see Iron Man's
bleeding-edge armor form around him with
nanobots or some sort of technology to
just make the suit around him in real
time while he's walking around you now
have the Black Panther vibranium
technology that does kind of the same
thing but it's more lightweight in a
looks more like fabric the way that
spider-man would wear a suit the upside
being is that he can still have his
web-shooters but he can have a costume
that can form out of a couple small
pieces so that he doesn't have to carry
his suit around in a bag he can actually
just form around him we all saw that
venom trailer we're all wondering about
how they're gonna tie that to the
spider-man mythology because venom has
the spider-man symbol on his chest and
you can't really justify having that
without having the symbiote have an
encounter with spider-man at some point
or any Brock have an encounter with him
the easiest way for them to do something
close to the symbiote without actually
going straight up venom inside the MCU
would be for him to just have a costume
that can change what it looks like
because vibranium is infinitely
malleable like you can actually make it
look red if you want you can actually
color it to look like the spider-man
costume so just because it's vibranium
doesn't mean that it has to be black
like the Black Panther costume there was
that trailer that I posted yesterday
where Black Panther talks about the
vibranium that Iron Man has and people
were like wait a minute what's he
talking about it has a lot of Natural
Resources one of those be vibranium
which you have so I'll add that link to
the end of the video but what I think he
was talking about was just Captain
America's shield like he actually does
still have cap shield because it was the
end of spider-man homecoming when they
were loading up the Avengers Tower now
that everybody's coming together during
the next two Avengers films everybody
keeps asking will iron me and get a
vibranium suit because he gets a new
version of the costume every single
movie that's just one of the cool things
that he does once you go see the Black
Panther movie there will be a little bit
more to talk about without getting into
spoilers I'll talk about specific stuff
at the end of this week I do think that
it's possible that during phase 4 if
Iron Man is still alive after both of
the Avengers films yes he will find a
way to make himself a vibranium soup but
there are too many theories too much
stuff up in the air about Robert Downey
jr. zalta metate in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe just because there are so many
ways that they can keep him around but
also kill him during infinity war and
I'm not talking about the time gem the
only thing that this clip confirms is
that at some point during Marvel phase
four spider-man will get a vibranium
suit I think for the
part for the next two Avengers films
he'll just be wearing that Tony Stark
iron spider suit but imagine a vibranium
suit during phase four in his own
spider-man movies they can just change
into whatever costume that he needs
because it's vibranium so it looks like
the classic spider-man suit that he wore
during homecoming but it can also become
whatever different version of the suit
he needs it to be the same way that the
symbiote would do that
so it functions like the symbiote but it
doesn't also try to take over his mind
the way that the symbiote did let me
know in the comments though when do you
want them to debut that new vibranium
version of his costume do you want them
to do it in the spider-man homecoming
sequel or do you want to see that during
a black panther sequel because they
don't talk about it during this
interview but I do think that if they're
gonna be collaborating on new versions
of costumes like sure he's gonna
actually be helping spider-man make his
new costume then it's possible the
spider-man crosses over with an X Black
Panther movie whenever that ends up
coming we don't know when spider-man 3
is gonna come out but I do think that
there'll be a spider-man 3 and I
definitely think there's gonna be a
black panther sequel during phase 4
there is a new round of that Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and share the
video using those tools on the watch
page congratulations to the winner for
my last video Aquos seven please private
message me so I can get your contact
details there were some really cool
details that released about Thor's new
weapon so I'll do a video for that
tomorrow but I have some new flash that
I'll post later tonight click here for
that new Black Panther infinity war
trailer and click here for new Deadpool
2 thank you so much for watching
everybody to stay awesome I'll see you
guys tonight
[Music]